welcome to google cloud
on air in this session we'll be talking
about high availability and disaster
recovery with cloud sql
my name is brett hesterberg i'm a
product manager working on cloud sql
and while we can't see each other today
i do hope to learn a little bit about
you as part of this talk
if you're comfortable doing so please
use your chat window or your question
window
to let me know your job title are you a
dba
a reluctant dba devops engineer
developer or something else
and which relational database you use
most often
is it mysql sql server oracle
postgresql sybase db2
sqlite or something else hopefully we
can still get a chance to get to know
each other a little bit and as a note
i'll be available as part of google
cloud next
expert sessions if you would like to
meet with me about cloud sql
today we're going to be talking about
concepts related to high availability
and disaster recovery
we'll start off a little bit with the
concepts themselves and go over some
terminology
from there we'll talk about how we
protect against user error
and then get into how we might achieve
high availability especially with
cloud sql and lastly we'll round out
with what to do when we have a disaster
how do we recover
so to start i'll give a little bit of
information about cloud sql itself
cloud sql is a managed database service
that offers mysql postgresql and sql
server
this means that if your application
works with mysql
sql server or postgresql it works with
cloud sql compatibility is at our core
and we focus on managing the mundane
aspects
of database administration when i think
about
database administration what it takes to
run a database this tends to be
the diagram that i think of in the left
hand column or left most column
we see server maintenance racking
stacking servers
hvac networking power things related to
managing a data center
or managing a server environment the
hardware itself of course in the cloud
this is taken care of for you and in
cloud sql with our sql instances
we ensure that when you configure a
number of vcpus
and some ram that you get a consistent
instance
regardless of as to what's happening
with your underlying hardware
we make sure that that instance
continues forward even when we have
hardware changes going on
looking a little further to the right on
the slide we see the column that
talks about the operating system this
includes installing the operating system
as well as patching it keeping it up to
date
right one more from there finally we get
to the database itself
but we're installing the database we're
keeping it patched and up to date
and lastly we're thinking about
protecting our data
with a set of backups finally on the
slide rightmost
we get into high availability usually
using replication
and some health checking to perhaps
perform automatic failover in the
in the event we have an incident or an
outage and also scaling thinking about
things like
using replication to scale out reads for
example we wrap
this entire technology stack in
monitoring so if there is a problem
we're able to understand where the root
cause is
and cloud sql's job here is to take this
what is
usually a complex technology stack and
wrap it in an api
and a ui so that your developers or your
application teams
are able to easily turn up a
dev or test database or even a much more
complex production database
which includes automatic failover for
high ability for high availability
built-in backups for data protection and
near real-time copies of data in other
regions in case of a regional failure or
an actual disaster
our customer tim kelton at descartes
labs i think sums this up pretty well
he says for his team cloud sql gives
him more time to work on the products
that provide value to their customers
what tim is saying is they would rather
spend time
on products that are meaningful to their
customers than on the mundane aspects of
database administration
and tim's team uses cloud sql to help
offset that time
one thing that we should note is that
cloud sql is backed by a 24x7
sre team site reliability engineering
team this is the team that writes the
automation to make sure our databases
are healthy our service runs well
and in the event of a problem that can't
be solved by automation
they're the folks who get hands on
keyboard to bring a database back to
life
as we talk about high availability and
disaster recovery it's important to
start with a little bit of terminology
to begin we'll talk about backups
backups are independent copies of the
data set
that isn't in the database serving path
this means we think about the databases
data set the data it's working on right
now
we usually make a copy of it an
independent copy sent to some other
storage system
so that that backup is no longer in the
serving path or the place where the
database is making changes to the
primary data set
in cloud sql we offer automated backups
which means
we take them daily for example at a time
that you set
we also offer on-demand or manual
backups where you can tell us
to take a backup and we'll take it in
that moment going beyond backups
we get to point in time recovery point
in time recovery is functionality
that often uses backups to restore
to a very granular point in time down to
for example the millisecond
as part of point in time recovery
usually we keep
transaction logs which contain a list or
a log of all transactions the database
has been running all the inserts updates
etc
so that we can go back to very granular
points in time
specific moments when a transaction was
run for example
also on the list is replication
replication is
a continuous copy of data from your
source or your primary database
to a replica or a secondary database
this means that we are making sure we
have either a real time or a near
real-time copy of data
in some other database from your primary
replication has two major options one is
synchronous
the other is asynchronous in a
synchronous replication model
a transaction is not fully committed
or is not responded to by the primary
instance to a client
until both the primary database instance
and its replica
have committed the transaction the
primary instance will wait for the
replica
to ensure that both have committed the
transaction
before it responds to the client saying
your transaction has now been committed
in asynchronous replication the primary
instance
doesn't wait for the replica in this
case the primary instance
simply commits the transaction and
without waiting for the replica to let
it know that it too
committed the transaction it responds to
the client saying
your transaction has been committed
we'll talk about how cloud sql uses both
of these
as as part of its availability and
disaster recovery protection mechanisms
the last two terms that we'll go over
here are recovery point objective and
recovery time objective
recovery point objective is the maximum
time period in which we might lose data
from our system due to an incident
spoken plainly this means that when we
take a backup
right now we allow the database to
continue to run so our backup in this
very moment
has the exact data set our database does
we have a full copy
and independent copy of t of the data
set from right now
but the database continues to perform
inserts and updates
changing the data set subsequent to our
backup
now there's data in the database that we
don't have in our backup
if we were to have an incident losing
our database right now
we would lose all of the transactions
that that were committed
after we took our backup when we talk
about a recovery point objective we're
setting an objective which states
we're only wanting to lose a particular
amount of data so for example
if our rpo were five minutes we would
ensure that we have a data protection
mechanism in place
such that we would not lose more than
five minutes of transactions for example
from one backup
to the next this is depicted in the
diagram on the slide as a backup which
is point one
and then an incident happening roughly
in the middle of the diagram
the difference or the timeline between
the backup and the incident
is it helps us define our recovery point
objective effectively quantifies how
much data we've lost in that incident
recovery time objective is the targeted
duration
of time that we allow to recover
the data that has previously been backed
up what this means is in the event of an
incident
and we want when we want to use one of
our data protection mechanisms to
recover
data we measure the amount of time it
takes
to perform the recovery from the backup
as an example
and get the database back up and running
that amount of time is known as our
recovery time
and we set an objective which states how
much time we will allow
for that process to happen in a critical
database system
usually the rpo recovery point objective
and rto
are pretty small values recovery point
objective perhaps measured in seconds
and recovery time objective perhaps
measured in minutes in less critical
systems or non-critical databases
these objectives may be much more
lenient with recovery point objectives
being much larger
and recovery time objectives being
longer where we're allowing
more data loss and more recovery time
and we define how we protect data the
mechanisms we use
the number of protections we put in
place to try to adhere
to our rpo and our rto
let's talk about protecting against user
error
in presentations like these often we
talk mostly about disasters and we
depict them with lightning bolts or fire
on the slides in reality much more
common
that human error is the culprit of data
loss we ourselves in some sense are the
disaster
perhaps i make a mistake i drop a table
i change a row
and i didn't mean to i want to get back
in time i want to undo
that change and i may not know by the
way that i made a mistake
for a couple hours for example how do we
protect against
that kind of user error which is far
more common in
enterprise it environments for any it
environment
with cloud sql i talked about using
backups and cloud sql as mentioned
offers both automated backups as well as
on-demand backups
in the screenshot we show a user
configuring automated backups
where the user's setting a time when we
take a backup automatically via cloud
sql
once per day with these backups it's
important to note that these are
storage leveler block level backups so
that we are minimizing the amount of
data
that we are tracking between backup so
that we are saving to another system
if we take a backup at this moment we
watch and track the number of block
changes
to the next time we take a backup which
means the size of backups
common question from customers is how
large will my backups be
it is more dependent on how busy or
active your database is
than on how frequently you take these
backups for example a very active
database
will generate quite large backup files
lots of block changes
from one backup to the next whereas a
largely an active database
won't generate many changes between
backups and even if we take backups
quite frequently
they might be very small you can imagine
a database not doing any work right now
if we take a
if we take a backup and wait a few
seconds and then take another one
the second backup may be extremely small
because we didn't have any subsequent
block changes between the backups
how can we do a little better than
backup so we're taking backups each day
that might mean we have a recovery point
objective of roughly 24 hours
where our worst case is that if we take
a backup yesterday
at 11 pm we have a problem today at 10
59 pm
almost exactly 24 hours since our last
backup but about a minute before we take
the next backup how can we do better
than this this is where point in time
recovery comes into play
as i mentioned point in time recovery
builds upon backups or uses backups
usually as part of the recovery
mechanism
here we're showing a screenshot of
setting up or rather recovering using
point in time recovery in cloud sql
what you see here is that we're using a
time stamp based
point in time here we're selecting down
to the millisecond
when we want to recover to in the past
cloud sql offers
transaction or timestamp based recovery
with point in time recovery
back seven days so it allows me to pick
a millisecond in
any of the last seven days to which i
want to recover to
this means if i've made a mistake as i
described earlier i might want to go to
the millisecond or even the second
before i made that mistake and in this
example we're cloning or copying a
database to that point
so i can go back and get that data bring
it back into my primary database
effectively undoing the mistake that i
made
with backup protections or data
protections rather in mind
let's now take a look at how to achieve
high availability
as a starting point you all have worked
in it environments for a long time and
you know that
high availability is not easy to achieve
it usually involves some combination of
replication
health checking and then some workflow
management in case we want to
automatically fail over in the event of
an incident
with high availability we usually begin
by talking about
data redundancy high availability often
relies on writing data
to two or more places so that in case of
an incident with our
primary database instance we have the
data elsewhere
and are quickly able to make it
available to recover from that incident
this type of configuration is sometimes
called a cluster
it simply means we're using two or more
database servers
to perform the tasks that one could
perform so that we have redundancy in
case of an
in case of an incident for cloud sql
it's important to note that the high
availability configuration is required
for sla coverage
our service level agreement or sla
guarantees a particular uptime
and as part of that sla we require that
high availability is enabled so that we
can automatically and quickly recover
from any incident that may affect your
database instance
when we talk about high availability in
cloud sql
this is conceptually what it looks like
when the high availability configuration
is enabled
we create a primary instance in a zone
and a standby instance in another zone
in this example we've created a primary
instance in zone a and a standby
instance in zone b
this ensures that we have redundancy in
our h a configuration such that if
there's a problem in zone a
we have a place to fail over to in an
instance that we can bring up quickly
to recover and be back online for our
client
also shown in the in the diagram is that
we're writing data
to two places at once we're using a
regional persistent disk
which synchronously replicates data in
both zones in this case zone a
and zone b so before the primary
database instance
will confirm to a client that a
transaction has been committed
it ensures that the data has been
written to both
zones when our system is operating
normally this means that we can reliably
fail over
to our standby zone knowing we have a
full copy of the data set
and every last committed transaction
will be present when we bring
the database back online in case of an
outage cloud sql does a number of things
from a workflow perspective most
important to note is that
we move the ip address and the name of
the primary instance to the standby
instance
this is important because an application
then need not
know about the failover itself it only
has to try to reconnect
because the ip address doesn't change to
the application
it simply looks like the database has
gone down and then has come back up
and by retrying the application can
reconnect
and begin serving traffic just after the
failover
to get used to or to get comfortable
with cloud sql's high availability
configuration
i recommend that you get hands-on you
can check it out for yourself in the
product
and you can initiate a failover in the
ui you'll see a failover button or vr
api you can also take a look at our code
labs we have a codelab
lab in particular that features
kubernetes engine and cloud sql
and talks about how you can build a
fault tolerant application where in the
lab
you will you will test fault tolerance
both in the application layer kubernetes
engine
as well as in cloud sql lastly
i encourage you to check out this
showcase that we've created for
google cloud next 2020. this showcase is
essentially a
whack-a-mole of databases where you can
see how many times you can make cloud
sql fail
and how many times it recovers by kind
of whack-a-mole style
taking down a database perhaps in zone a
and seeing it pop back
up in zone b the link is shown in the
slide and i encourage you to take a look
let's round out with a look at
recovering in case of a large disaster
and here you and your careers have
likely spent a lot of time
planning and you've been testing for
large disasters hopefully you haven't
faced many real ones
in google terms when we think of a
disaster we tend to think of this as a
regional outage where a regional is con
region is comprised of usually three or
more zones independent failure domains
and this would mean something has
happened such that
all the zones or enough of the zones in
a region are down that the region does
not have connectivity it is totally down
as you can imagine this has significant
consequences as any disaster would when
you're doing your disaster recovery
planning
you're imagining usually that most of
the applications if not all
that serve your internal users and your
external customers
may be down and in that moment the job
is
to make sure that we can recover quickly
and perform the recovery such that we
lose a minimum set of data
a stressful moment to be sure let's look
at how cloud sql has tried to make this
a little easier we've introduced
cross-region replication to help guard
against
regional failure it allows you to have a
near real-time copy
via a replica in one or more regions
outside of your primary region
we're relying on google's network
including google cloud vpc
or virtual networks so that you have a
very private way to connect
between your primary instance and its
replicas in other regions
further because google's vpcs are global
there's
very minimal network configuration for
you to perform here
a google vpc spans all regions in in the
cloud network
all the regions you're using which makes
this very easy to use and to configure
in fact you see in the screenshot here
highlighted all we're doing is selecting
a region
other than our primary region when we're
creating a replica and we can be
certain that the replica is being spun
up in another region
and we're connecting from our primary to
our replica in a very secure fashion
over our private network with the
replica now deployed in another region
let's look at
what's actually happening behind the
scenes in this diagram
you see a high availability
configuration
in a primary region in this case u.s
central one
here again we're using synchronous
replication within the region to ensure
that we can automatically fail over
without losing committed transactions
between regions or outside of the
primary region to your replicas
we're using asynchronous replication as
you recall from our terminology section
asynchronous replication means the
primary instance
is not waiting for the replicas to
commit their transactions
before it tells the client the
transaction has been committed
we do that because the latency can be
higher between regions
given the geographic distance between
them we don't want to
harm performance in the primary region
by waiting for every replica around the
world to say
i also have committed the transaction
and so we replicate asynchronously
this has ramifications for your recovery
point objective
it means that you can potentially have
replication lag
usually on the order of seconds but your
replica doesn't have
the exact real-time copy of the data set
the primary has
it has a near real-time copy something
that's perhaps a few seconds
in the past from what has now happened
on the primary instance bear this in
mind especially in your disaster
recovery plan
in this diagram though we see two
replicas again these could be in
any regions in the world even in
separate regions allowing us to ensure
that we have
a very near real-time copy of data
elsewhere and that allows us from an rto
perspective recovery time objective
perspective
in case of a regional outage of our
primary region
to offer roughly a one to three minute
recovery time
where we can promote these replicas to
become
read and writeable to serve application
traffic
in the event of an outage it allows you
to build
a database configuration that adheres to
fairly strict rpo
and rto objectives or recovery time
objectives rather
in case of a widespread or a regional
outage
one thing to note here is the replicas
themselves are always readable
so you are able not only to see which
data has landed on your replicas but if
you have
use cases such as reporting or maybe you
just want to offer lower latency reads
to
users in other parts of the world cross
region replicas are a good way to go
to accomplish that to wrap up here
we want to recommend that for especially
critical systems
in your environment with cloud sql you
enable automatic daily backups
and point in time recovery for very
granular or
millisecond level recovery you should
also consider taking more frequent
on-demand backups
these can be useful if you're making for
example a schema change you may want to
take an on-demand backup just before you
make the schema change
of course point in time recovery can be
used to perform that restoration as well
but it never hurts to take an additional
backup especially when you know you're
going to be making a big change
next we encourage you to enable in
region high availability our synchronous
replication models the cloud sql can
help check your instances can
automatically fail over in the event of
an incident
and make sure that you're back online
without any intervention and lastly
consider using in-region or more
importantly cross-region replication
which is asynchronous replication to
make sure you have a near real-time copy
of your data
in another region than where your
primary instance resides
that way in case of a regional failure
or disaster you have a near real-time
copy of data that can be made accessible
quite rapidly adhering to a fairly
strict rto
with that i encourage you to tune in to
two additional sessions
first being data modernization which is
mckesson's story of their migration to
cloud
and then take a look at our bare metal
solution which helps you bring your
enterprise workloads
to gcp if you want to see the showcase
that i mentioned
in action please follow this link and
play our whack-a-mole style high
availability
uh demo lastly try it out for yourself
get hands-on with cloud sql by following
our quick lab quest
you'll be introduced to a number of
cloud sql's capabilities
including those that i mentioned today
and by the end you'll be quite familiar
with cloud sql
with that i want to thank you for
joining me today for this session
as mentioned i'm available for expert
sessions as part of google cloud next
2020 and i look forward to meeting you
thank you
you